hello I'm Neil Gaiman's and an author
and I'm here to talk to you about
something that concerns all of us
it's something called All Hallows reads
the idea of it is incredibly simple this
Halloween
gives somebody a scary book to read
that's it that's the idea it's very a
tradition in ten years time everybody is
going to be giving somebody else or lots
of somebody else's a scary book for
Halloween but for right now we're
starting a fish All Hallows read we're
not saying don't give candy candy is
important Candy's important fake blood
is important
zombie teeth incredibly important do
they have zombie key if they have zombie
teeth they'd be incredibly important the
point is give somebody a scary book give
kids scary books the kids would like
give adults scary books and adults alike
if you have friends give them the kind
of scary books the friends would like
buying the scary books for them borrow
scary books not get them secondhand
check them out of your library your
local librarian will be a fine source of
information on scary books so your local
bookseller
the important thing is all hallows rain
did somebody a scary book this Halloween
and spread the joy by the town
you
you